my name is I am from the autonomy
penetrance and love the competitiveness
council the group is working together at
defining competitiveness for the better
of this world how can we learn from each
other what is the best way of delivering
a competitive competitive environment we
have looked at many issues around
competitive motion namely governance
APB's areas of collaboration between the
government and the private sector we
have looked at some of the risks that
are also associated with the new
competitiveness so this is in brief what
we have looked at today during our
meeting at the competitiveness Council